is that good
well i mean i know there's three
different types right there's o a b and
a b
yeah uh yeah absolutely rare one right a
b is the real one
i mean i i should know because i have
like a blood disease so i i used to have
a medical bracelet
yeah you probably shouldn't you know you
should know shouldn't you have a medical
bracelet uh
that would be like you know if i if i
i'm bleeding please give me this thing
specifically
do you know what your parents are uh no
but then i lost that i lost the medical
bracelet so i don't know where it is
so uh the one thing you probably
shouldn't lose i haven't got a
replacement it's been like a few years
now so
are you meant to like wear that always
not meant to it's just like a suggestion
from the doctor blows my
mind what blows my mind though is that
in japan at least like in japanese
schools like
you can get bullied for your blood type
that's right damn man that's
that's next level bullying it's like
it's like oh you're an a type that's
just racism with extra steps man
yeah that does sound like an excuse it's
like i bet he's a filthy old type yeah
you can't hang out with us because
you're an a type right
and like because why does everyone know
each other's blood type
yeah i think i think it's because like
when you do like uh health checks
oh yeah we did that yeah i haven't done
mine yet but
it should be written on your thing that
was that was so strong so so to explain
since we're starting with geeks plus we
are technically under their health
insurance and their company policy is
that we have to get a
health checkup once a year which
everyone in japan has to do work
everyone in japan
twice a year okay twice we've been here
for
one year already mail in but we've
already had one checkup how does that
work
okay okay so we're supposed to go twice
but we've
only just been once um and it was
weird because i it was weird seeing how
efficient
a health system can be yeah how long did
it take cause i haven't
gone yet it took about 20 minutes what
did it's like 30. okay well third so
still that's
so in 30 minutes you do an x-ray
uh your blood pressure you get weighed
you get blood taken
uh you do a hearing and uh site test
yeah
you talk to a doctor who will talk to
you and then you do a cardiogram and a
cardiogram yeah wow
30 minutes all inside it was like it was
like
speed running we we were speed running
health checks and
they even had like [ __ ] splits as
well because
x-ray split done all right blood taking
split let's go
it literally felt like that because it
was like because i was
about like uh because i had some
problems with my forms i had to fill out
my form again so i was only about like
five to ten minutes behind
conor yeah and by the time i had just
like just started my
like i've never called it i'm gonna call
it a conveyor belt because that's what
it felt like it felt like i was in
chicken run being processed
um so i was i i had just started the
process and conor was almost done
wow it was the most efficient
because i saw the list of all the things
that get checked up and i was like oh
this is going to be like an all day yeah
you also have to pee the night before
and bring it with you which i just
always feel weird
oh yeah i do have to do carrying a a
violin
who knows so you go into this room and
it's like this really
busy place in like shinjuku which i
imagine a lot of people will go to the
world in japan
and then there's uh like you go to this
uh reception area there's like 12 desks
like come here you hand the form like
right go upstairs you go upstairs yeah
everyone's in like medical gowns yeah
like a really fancy office looking thing
all right it's really odd
and it's basically just a small room not
even that big with like couches in the
middle
and then you can see the like sections
like it's a food court of like what's
gonna do
you can see everyone getting that blood
taken you can see everyone you see
everyone doing everything yeah yeah and
then
you they're like all right go in this
room get changed so you put the medical
camera you come back in and then like
right
you have a number so you're literally
like a chicken in a farm
it's like actually chicken a piece of
meat being like passed around the
different things
yeah you gotta get sanitized you know
and so you just they basically just come
in they're like
number 124 and then you go in and then
you just have to like
hopefully understand what they're saying
wow yeah they tell you
yeah it was just fast it was like boom
boom boom wow but i was like [ __ ] dude i
hate blood tests i hate getting my blood
taken yeah god i haven't done that in a
while
and then i was like i was just yeah yeah
yeah i got to do my next week
yeah it's fun it's fun is it no it's not
it's it's as fun as a health check can
be because i it was something
that was so alien for me especially
coming from the uk which you know
big up the nhs forgetting giving
everyone everyone free health care but
the price you pay for that
is that you have to wait for everything
yeah yeah yeah
and when i say everything even just
going to the [ __ ] gp
it's sometimes yeah sometimes you're
like you got a fever or something i've
phoned up my gp
and they're like oh we can't six days
yeah we can't book you in until next
week and i'm just like great i guess
i'll just
try to sleep off this i guess for an
entire week
and by the time you can see the gp
you've already most of the time you've
already recovered yeah i think i never
see the doctor in london but i booked
three times to see it when i was like
dying and every time before the
appointment i got better and i had to
cancel it
because it was like i'm already better
right it literally takes a week at least
in london it's even
it's worse but i remember like i would
like i think i thought i broke my arm
one time when i was a kid
and i was i was in the emergency room
and i'm like [ __ ] dude i'm going to get
an x-ray and they're like yep so uh
come back in a week and a half and we'll
give you an x-ray i'm like
what like what do i just do in a week
like what about my arm yeah like yeah
come back in a week and a half i'm like
but
what do i do till then but like oh just
don't do anything to it i'm like what do
you mean don't do anything to it
all right what i should have to do for a
week and a half not move my arm that's
so stupid well yeah and it was so weird
going to the japanese health checkup and
they like
they started off with the x-ray because
like when i think x-ray i'm just like in
in my head i'm just like
i'm not getting an x-ray unless it's
something serious so this is obviously
like
the big checkup this is the x-ray but no
they [ __ ] lubed us up lubed us up
with a [ __ ] x-ray man
like we went in there and we just like
they they go please go to the x-ray
machine
it's just like a rectangle on a wall
and you just put your chest against it
yeah it's really odd oh because when i
imagine x-ray i
imagine like the light yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i always had that it
was bizarre
because i've never i've never had an
x-ray done before yeah what was weird
actually was the cardiogram
which uh where you like i've never had
that before yeah i've never had that
before
it's like lie down on the bed and you
kind of feel like a mental patient about
to get lobotomized
because they put these suckers on you
they put these suckers on you and then
they they
put these appendages on your uh on your
heart and your arms and legs yeah right
and yeah it just kind of feels like
you're about to get the bottom i was
waiting for like the electric shock to
come
i was like go hit me but no nothing
happened then they
they like they had to lube me up as well
yeah yeah yeah
they just put like lube on you because i
think i had chest hair all right so
it doesn't go what maybe yeah what do
you mean it's
it's a natural medicine is uh
i'm not talking about my in-depth
colonoscopy maybe maylin's off screen
just like blushing which by the way
which by the way like the smallest
details i was i was told if you're over
35
every year you have to have a
colonoscopy really yeah every year you
have to have a colonoscopy
it's because it's because uh japan in
japan hemorrhoids is a really common
problem
i'm legit i'm legit serious like i think
it's
i think i saw something like crazy like
one in four men
in japan have hemorrhoids yeah conor was
telling me afterwards that he he doesn't
want a colonoscopy because he's
afraid that it'll awaken
because i was i was momentarily confused
i was a colonoscopy on my way
i'm like which end is that
i'm like because i thought about it
would you rather something go up your
ass or down your throat
yeah i thought he thought he was going
down your throat so they check your
throat or down like no that's what's
what's that called that's a different
thing
something else and i was like i was like
totally down i'm like all right fine put
it on my ass
down my throat whatever up my ass no no
it's the opposite way
i'd rather something
when we were doing this health checkup
as well they would like we had like the
the blood pressure thing yeah the thing
in it which also always feels weird
that squeezes your arms yeah yeah and
then the doctor was like yeah you did
you did good on that i'm like what does
that mean
what does that mean what is doing bad
i'm like i'm like explain what did good
means that your numbers are good i'm
like yeah
explain the [ __ ] numbers to me what
is this supposed to mean i got
i was like i put all my attention into
my arm to change my blood pressure yeah
i was i was doing something like hunter
hunter men [ __ ] on that thing i'm like
heart rate zero you did like avatar
blood bending [ __ ] it's just like yeah
yeah i will now make my heart rate zero
so my enemies cannot find me
then we got a blood taken and i remember
we were before we got a blood thing we
were talking about you know
yeah we were talking about how the
japanese health system had we've had
we've all had pretty good
experiences with the japanese health
system because we all have like i don't
know why
we all have like that inherent fear that
you know everyone's had a shitty
shitty experience when they have taken
the blood and they've just missed the
vein
right yeah yeah and that happened to me
that really yeah that like it was
foreshadowing that happened to me
because i i knew it as soon as he stuck
the needle in because you know
you you can feel it when when like it
goes straight to your vein
it feels exactly like the doctor
describes it's just like a prick right
yeah and it just comes out
so he sticks this needle in and i could
feel immediately
that something was wrong because it was
like that's not a vein that's muscle and
you start feeling pain
and i felt i'm sorry for anyone who has
like a needle phobia because i'm gonna
i'm not like so i can feel him like kind
of twitching the needle around
in my arm and i'm just like i'm just
like how do i tell him it's not there
how do i tell him it's not there
and he does it for like a full like
minute before he realizes
oh there's no blood coming out and i
look and i look i was just pulling up
fat like yeah i mean
i look over and there's like you know
you know like the vial of blood
yeah there's like the vile the vial was
filled up that much
like the minute he was poking my arms
like scar tissue yeah
i was like god [ __ ] man i knew it so
i
was so embarrassed i was like [ __ ] i
want to be cool and not like like [ __ ]
myself yeah
yeah but then i was like oh god and i
was like oh no the nurse is cute oh no i
can't i'm gonna no i think with needles
i feel needles are the only time where
you can bring out your inner [ __ ] and
just be like i don't i don't know i
can't look at the needle going in
i like oh i i have to look at the needle
going you do
yeah i i like it's on the contrary for
me if i
if he's like all right we're gonna go in
and if i don't see it and i feel a prick
that scares me joey
jerry's just like he's like it's going
in yeah no legit i have to go like i do
and i'm just being like do it do it now
wait so what about
wait what about staring at you being
like pierced helps you
because i know when the pain is coming
what
you know what i mean
then you're expecting the pain no no
what's worse for me is unexpected pain
where i'm just like i'm just chilling
you barely feel it if you don't look
though
no no no i feel a more if i don't yeah
because that's that's like
have you have you ever like cut yourself
or have like an injury you don't feel it
all day
yeah and then suddenly you look at it
and you're like wow there's a cut and
then suddenly you start feeling it
yeah yeah that's me that's me a needle
really because every time i get cut it's
just like
a pain like i can't imagine seeing blood
literally gush out of my veins and
thinking
yeah that's uh that looks like it's not
gonna lie like during the summer for
instance like because like during the
summer your blood pressure is a lot
higher yeah
so when the blood comes out it kind of
just like gushes out and i'm just like
oh that looks sick
i like looking at that it's kind of cool
i i missed one i remember
like well that's coming out of my body
[ __ ] i remember as a kid they would just
give me this like contraption that was
just like filled with like paint oil and
it would just like all of it would like
you would flip it over and
start playing like crazy yeah you should
do that to distract to distract yourself
yeah because i was like wow look at that
thing going i just
look at the vial i'm like whoa that's
cool that's weird i can't do that
really i was just like i put my hand on
the table i'm like go ahead
you smacked it i was like i was like i
was like kawaii man
go ahead what why'd you have to like
smack it
i'm like come on get ready boy belt in
the mouth yeah
i'm like using mine we're using mine it
was weird for me because
because normally when i get my blood
taken i'm used to it being like
uh like a private place you know what i
mean in front of everyone
yeah and so i'm sorry so we had our
blood takens like a conveyor and i was
just like eyeing up the next guy
the guy next to me again three of us
right here was getting our blood taken
it was very odd neither of us could look
at the look at the blood getting taken
and we just [ __ ] like met eyes and
just like
all right well it's it's it's kissed
yeah it's like meeting guys in a urinal
but you know it's just like so this is
awkward how's your day going oh that's
that's a
that's you look like a no-type there
[ __ ] you like
what are you trying to say i was trying
to strike up any conversation i guess it
is odd that we kind of
made it into a private thing in the west
right like does it really need to be
private getting your blood taken
like i mean it doesn't but i would i i
feel more i think
i think it's that people would prefer it
right like i prefer it but if
if that means that you know i get
medical tests way [ __ ] quicker in the
uk yeah by all means do my colonoscopy
in front of the other patients i
i do not mind like let's get this done
it's like oh you crack the fat too
high five if that means i can get it
done twenty percent faster and i can get
on with my day yeah
i'll i'll i'll get it i'll get my blood
if i faint in front of a group of twenty
people who cares that's that's why in my
head i was like oh this is gonna be an
all all-day thing
because anywhere else it's definitely an
all-day thing right yeah
yeah well i think the worst part was
that you couldn't eat uh or drink
anything the night before
oh really after like 8 p.m you have to
stop eating and drinking and yeah
normally that wouldn't be a problem but
when you tell me i can't
eat and drink i'm like well [ __ ] now i
want to
well no i want to just wait you can't
even drink water are you drinking
i was going to say drink but water's the
only thing you can drink you won't have
any alcohol i was like
british people like shaking tea tea
yeah basically no substance like in your
bloodstream
um the knife is a substance yeah what
are you what are you taking
god god's like you gotta you gotta put
the belt and spoon away
oh god that's your damn are they gonna
see my heroine veins and everything man
please make sure to hit the heroin bane
don't worry i got this i've i've done
this before
i'm kidding this is a joke now why don't
you take karen
yeah well in case you don't get sarcasm
none of us have done heroin
okay it's more
oh my god